is there a standard structure for
television
yeah and and it can vary especially
depending on what your
what Outlet you're writing for so when
you're staffed right you're writing to
whatever the network or the streaming
service does
there's a variety of different
structures that that brings about for
instance most of the ABC dramas that I
know of I will not say all about any of
them are written in 6X structure so what
6X structure means is that you're you're
basically everything's kind of a little
symmetrical right you've got this many
pages here this many pages in each Act
get building to those act out through
those commercial breaks and because it's
so act out driven it really changes the
pacing of the show if you watch most ABC
shows will feel like they move very
quickly and it's because of that sort of
symmetrical nature of the ax
shows on CBS are often teaser4 is the
structure it's also often called five
act structure it sort of just depends on
who's referring to it but what it does
is allow you to write a longer teaser
that can sometimes be more luxurious and
get more of your story set up
and then you you use the following four
acts to you know complete your
storytelling shows that I I will say I
think have done that or like The Good
Wife right would sometimes have those
really long opening setups before the
title card so that's your long luxurious
teaser and then the rest of the show is
the 5x structure
um
so those that's sort of the main stuff
six act teaser four or five Act five act
tends to
um
have a shorter teaser that than the
basically starts act one so it's like
short teaser title card rest of act one
as opposed to being a separate entity
like teaser four is
um so those are the varying sort of
different things and you can you know
again if you can get a hold of scripts
for different shows you can research how
they did it in streaming shows when you
read our scripts there there won't be
any act designations because there are
typically no commercial breaks although
now that you know Netflix is going to
have an ad tier I don't know if that's
going to change or they're going to ask
us to tell them where the commercial
breaks are like we do in broadcast TBD
but
um again to something I spoke about
earlier and that I think is really
important breaking the story as if those
act breaks exist
will help with your storytelling and
help with the emotional ebb and flow of
the episode so that it doesn't feel like
you're waiting till the end of the show
to do all the really important things
because I think what happens is people
are like well we can have all these nice
long conversations or we can have this
great big huge set piece but then you're
not really getting a lot of variation in
the episode it's just sort of like talk
talk talk talk everything happens where
it's like talking talking huge set piece
talking talking talking boom ending and
that's like a it's not really a great
pleasurable experience when you watch TV
you want to sort of like be drawn in and
then like okay I can rest a little bit
um so that that act break structure even
if you take act breaks out of your
script is a really good way to do it
how is the structure of a Netflix
60-minute show different from a
60-minute cable TV show
the biggest difference is are you if
you're referring to Cable as in like
free form effects those kind of things
are that those platforms still include
commercial breaks so you are still
writing to an act out and what that
really means for the writer is that you
are creating a moment that you hope
assures that your audience will come
back after the commercial break now
obviously some those shows will move to
a streaming platform there will not be
commercials in them so you that gets
eliminated at that point but when
they're airing on their actual
originating broadcasters that's the
whole goal that's what an act out is all
about is holy crap what just happened
and you're like come on commercials come
on commercials go go Google or you
recorded it so you can fast forward
through all the commercials and then
your show is back
um so you know for a streaming show for
say Netflix or
for you know Amazon or for free well
freebie has ads but for Amazon Prime
itself those are not they're not worried
about your act breaks so you can you
lose page count in your script to act
breaks when you're doing them for say a
broadcast show like when you have four
lines at the top of a page and then it's
like end of act you're done with that
page like all that blank space is lost
to you if you're doing a streaming show
and you're breaking it with AC breaks
but you're not putting them in the
script it's just one long continuous
thing so you've probably bought yourself
back four pages of script just by not
having act breaks so it'll allow you to
expand a little bit sometimes when you
need to
um the trick with the
60 Minute show I have written yet to
write on a Netflix show and I have
written on three of them now where 60
Minute episodes were actually what we
were delivering we've both still
delivered like 52 wish 50 52 to 55
minutes
so in general I know they have shows
that will have longer episodes but in
general that's still the target so
you're still looking at you know turning
in a 52 to 55 page script in the hopes
if not you don't ever want to run short
but you also don't want to be 10 minutes
over because now you're going to have to
kill a lot of scenes that you love in
order to get it down so trying to find
that sweet spot of being like four or
five minutes over so you can cut a few
things but you know still have some
choices and some some good moments
around is kind of the goal
can you explain a b and c stories sure
so
in most shows you will have your a story
is the main story of the episode it is
the driving story usually of your main
characters
uh not always true but often true
and so say for instance and I'll use
SWAT as an example because we very
clearly wrote A B and C stories so your
a story is the crime of the week right
what who are the bad guys who are
challenging what have they done what are
we trying to stop them from doing
and you will develop that whole story
and who in our cast is that story really
affecting right now 8 out of 10 episodes
that's going to be Hondo but sometimes
it's a personal case from the past for
one of our other characters or it's
someone's friend was injured in the
crime and so they're the ones who are
emotionally affected by what we're doing
so that's your a story your B story and
your C story
are the supporting stories in the
episode and they are usually more
character focused
so it's a chance for your second tier
characters to sort of get moments right
so say again in an episode of SWAT a b
story might be
um
Street and Chris have like admitted that
they like each other but they're still
like oh can we date no we can't date
what are we gonna do about this mess so
that romantic Intrigue is your B story
sometimes it also will cross into your a
story right because it's like
they're on a call together and they've
just had this fight about the fact that
they can't date each other but then like
something dangerous happens and then
it's so clear that how much they love
each other right so it's like you're
building that stuff into the a story but
you're breaking their arc on its own
and then a c story is usually a runner
right it's like a three four beat story
that sometimes adds some humor to the
episode sometimes it's to tie off a
loose end that we've left floating from
a prior episode of like did that couple
break up we don't know and so we'll do
like three beats where we finally reveal
like did the couple break up oh no no
they're still together look at that
surprise like whatever it is
um sometimes it's a way to give an actor
who has maybe not been as focused on in
the show a chance to shine so you're
giving them three or four scenes that
are really about them and their
character and letting them sort of like
you know hey I'm here pay attention to
me so
that's really what those things break
down to it's your main story your
secondary story and then see story is
usually a runner
um you will sometimes like in a finale
episode your B and C stories will feel
about equal because you know finales are
all about wrapping up the emotional arcs
of the entire season so sometimes it's
like you've got three relationship
stories going and you have to get
somewhere with all of them so
you'll you know you suss that out in the
moment but that's in general how that
works
what do writers get wrong about TV
structure I think the imbalance can
happen a lot the everything happens in
the beginning or the end and not enough
attention to holding the story in the
middle right you you can start with a
big bang but you have to keep building
investment through the episode or else
people won't be around to see your big
finish
so it's just that reminder of like the
story has to keep building on itself and
sometimes you see people like just sort
of think this story can coast and it it
can't like you need to keep building the
investment of your audience of like oh
my God she overheard that is she gonna
tell them she ever heard it you're
waiting to find out like is she gonna
tell them and then maybe you don't even
get an answer that episode but like I'm
leaning forward now because I'm like she
overheard the thing though she overheard
the thing
so it's just that it's I think that's
the biggest mistake is not realizing
that you can have a big beginning and a
big finish but if the stuff in between
isn't peaking the interest of your
audience they're going to tune out and
that's the worst thing that can happen
to you because they may not make it to
your big finish
and so you can't count on that to be why
someone's going to keep watching the
show